ce gamin ne passe pas
inaperçu j'ai un visuel sur la cible il
a pas l'air aussi dangereux que ça les
apparences sont parfois trompeuses Votre
Altesse vous êtes sûr que vous n'avez
pas besoin de renfort non j'ai un truc
avec les
enfants vous pensiez que l'histoire é
terminé mais elle ne faisait que
commencer je ne suis pas un adepte des
suites
normalement mais les choses se sont un
peu
[Musique]
compliquées dans le
multivers
qui est ce sacré beau
[Musique]
gosse
je vous
cherche depuis très
longtemps soyez
prudents je ne voudrais pas avoir à
raconter ce qui pourrait vous
arriver
[Musique]
d code rouge en cour des terroristes se
sont emparés de l'immeuble le soir de
Noël c'est quoi les ailes de l'enfer non
attendez piège en haute mer non non non
c'est passage John mlein
[Musique]
concentrez-vous